let's go next to our caller from the six
one nine area code who's calling today
from six one nine I I think it's me can
you hear me yes who's this the biggest
question for every meeting you my name
is Leslie Valerie your name's yes
Gallery what's going on really me okay
and I'm so happy to finally meet you
have been watching me since I'm even so
you went I have a question regarding for
example I have so many questions but you
you are a journalist and I thought your
watching you way back then right but
they do already have a degree like to be
a journalist or did you just start going
out and like do things on your own like
the way that you have been now on
YouTube I started the show when I was 21
in college so I was not working in media
at the time that I started the show how
did you you know how did you learn all
the things that you've learned how how
is it now that you get to go and
interview and like have these amazing
things that you do how did you do it
it's a lot of learn by doing you just
each day you try to do it a little bit
better a lot of reading a lot of
practice it's it's been it's been a
learn on the job sort of thing for me
for example me I don't really happen yet
much money right now
and I'm not really technically employed
but I really would love to do things
like this but you know like like how you
get to interview and stuff how can I get
my foot in the door just to do this type
of stuff like on anything go like
there's so many things that we still
don't know about for example like you
know how exceeds these slightly
mentioned things about the drug crisis
homelessness they do mention on the news
but it kind of like and I feel like we
should get to know more of people's
problems of how one thing is correlated
with the other so in social problems are
just not
on the news as we should be and
therefore I feel like politicians don't
talk about it as much as it should be
and therefore there's no priority so
these type of issues that are actually
there everything in our life yes and the
question was how can you get involved in
media anymore like yeah Isis it isn't
like please like me I'm broke
how can someone like me believe oh cool
you know how can I just volunteered my
time I'm learning you know I just want
to be able to do this right well two
options the way I started was at a
community radio station in Massachusetts
where you just show up and they often
have sliding scale fees where you can
just start learning and it doesn't cost
you anything so look to see if there's a
community radio station in your area but
the great thing about if you I'm
guessing you have a phone since you're
calling me on the phone you can even use
your own to start citizen journalism and
citizen activism so fortunately the
barriers to entry have been drastically
reduced and it's an exciting time
Valerie I so appreciate the call and I
hope to hear from you again great to
hear from you